it's that time again to talk to you
about the latest games in new releases
and this week is officially the best
episode of new releases for 2015 so far
because dying light is parkouring its
way onto current-gen consoles and PC
this survival horror game puts you in a
zombie apocalypse open world where you
precariously move through a dangerous
urban environment crafting weapons for a
more gory finished those ghastly undead
foes the dynamic day and night cycle
also enhances gameplay allowing you to
be more aggressive in the Sun but more
elusive at night because those zombies
get the ability to sprint jump and climb
their way into your heart literally good
night and good luck on the 27th sweet
90s nostalgia it's been over 15 years
since the original release of grim
fandango a dark comedy neo-noir
adventure game about the land of the
dead man e calaveras stuck in a dead-end
sales job trying to upsell the recently
deceased into fancy comfortable travel
into the ninth underworld but everything
changes when acute Dame named mercedes
enters his life beautifully written with
a casablanca style this critically
acclaimed game is a must play or you'll
regret it take the luxury Express to
number nine on the 27th in the
not-too-distant future technologically
advanced humans face off against a
Truffaut self-replicating nanobots that
are eating the environment and
everything else that gets in their way
but there's another player on the field
an alien race calling themselves the
beta they're also in the mix and
fighting for their lives the result is
real-time strategy that looks incredibly
promising the hype is real now this came
out last week but it's worth mentioning
now so go check out grey goo and now we
enter a fresh world of a young girl with
worldly time-travel powers in an
episodic five-part series that seems to
blend Walking Dead the butterfly effect
and heavy rain into an interactive drama
graphic adventure that will leave you
wanting more
the rewinding time mechanic will allow
the player to change decisions they made
to see the different results to Maxine's
life and relationships once a girl in
town goes missing max must investigate
the disappearance and unravel the city's
secrets become an alternative high
school photography major just like you
always wanted on the 30th finally a
beautifully whimsical game comes to PC
this week with gravity ghost with a
light-hearted soundtrack and easygoing
gravity based gameplay you'll find
yourself relaxed and smiling at this
adorable and happy painted space
adventure feel the space bliss oh yeah
the dreamy colorful concoction releases
on the 26 for further details visit
gamespot com release dates are based on
retailer listings and are subject to
change see you next week
Oh
you